hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chattingcensus.com
in this video i want to talk about the
dxy which is the dollar index
let's get into it
so the dxy so basically this is uh the
value of one dollar
against the basket of currency so it
basically shows you
the strengths of the dollar in the world
so uh it's the first time i do an
analysis on this
currency so let's start it like on the
daily time frame
and i'm gonna see what happened in the
past five
to ten years so the very first thing
uh let's watch at what happened after
2015
so basically i see that uh this market
is renji
it has a lower band around 88
and a higher band around 103.6
103.5 something like this how i know it
because here you can see that we had
uh some buildup here so the
the price uh the price action was
contained here for one or two months so
i know this is an important level and
then here
it has been tested once twice twice
rejected and then it went higher
so this is uh the level i have as a
lower band
if i check a bit uh what happened on the
longer term
what do i see guys it's not a surprise i
can see that this
level was actually a resistance already
you can see here that it has been tested
in 208 209 and 2 or 10 one
two three times and then here it got
broken
retested we go higher we re-test we go
higher
all right so this is a basic technical
analysis
about a horizontal trend line all right
now
i am trading in this area for the past
five years
and there is something very interesting
to see guys
so we are right now in a descending
wedge pattern for the past
six to eight months alright and
what happened three years ago look
exactly the same thing
we were in a descending wedge pattern
and
it actually last for around nine months
something like this one year
um and before it got broken on the
upside
we had what we call a buildup here
so it's basically investors that are
buying the dip uh
and that are just building you know so
you have here a lot of selling pressure
but you can see that here
some bulls are coming up in the game and
they
basically uh are covering the flows uh
that are
sent by the bears and that's why the
price is not going lower why here
because we had a build up here so it's
not like uh
a surprise that this level was buyer um
and so i expect the same thing to happen
uh right now
so i think that it can go lower it can
go to 89.5 something like this so
basically i would be a buyer in this
area
and i would build a massive long
position and i would play the breakup on
the upside
of this dollar pair so basically
it would bring me in i think january
february you know something like this
and i think that here we have two
scenarios either
we break it on the downside uh which
means that the dollar is very very weak
but when i look at this move this is
something that wants to break on the
upside for me so i'm
mo i think there is still some downside
but i'm bullish in the middle term on
this
uh dollar index and guys for those who
have watched the video i did yesterday
on the s p 500 where i basically explain
that 3750 is the target of my fifth wave
of the fifth wave of the
recovery that we had since march and
that it would probably
be reached around jan or feb and here
guys what do you see
you know it's independent analysis but
they converge to the same
um to the same idea they give you the
same signal they tell you that
if there is a rush on the dollar in
jenna fab we're gonna break it on the
upside
very strongly as we did here guys
history repeats itself and this is why
technical analysis
is actually working it's because same
causes
will give you the same consequences and
even if it was a few years ago
people may have forgot but they're going
to behave the same way if the same
things happen
you know it's going to be different
people but the mass
psychology effect makes that the result
is gonna be the same
and the result might be a rush for the
dollar if there is a rush for the dollar
guys what is happening on the equity
market basically
it's gonna be uh sold massively and this
is going to be the correction
of the move up that we had since march
and that could go
as low as maybe 3 3200 on the s p500 i
don't know yet
but definitely it means that things are
shifting and that
uh the markets are gonna start to be
shaky even maybe bloody all right so
this is a leading indicator i always
keep an eye on the dxy because
it tells you first you know the flows on
the forex market
are leading you know they give you some
information about what people
do what people need to do for example
the rush for the dollar
means insecurity means people are not
sure they're going to be able to pay
back the debts in dollars so they buy
some dollar to feel safe
to be able to pay back the debt so
that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video i
hope i'm managed to make myself clear to
show you
like how the dollar index is actually
linked to the equity and
why it is very important to always keep
an eye on despair
and if you did please hit the like
button and the subscribe button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys